はい皆さんこんにちは道元です最近
チャットGPT4がえっと公開されました
ということで今日はこのAIツールを自分
の日本語の勉強に使えるかどうかっていう
のを試してみたいと思っていますであの
かなり優秀みたいなので
最初からちょっと難しい
質問をしてみたいと思っていますそれでは
やっていきましょう雨
[音楽]
Rainの
工程アクセントを教えてください
[音楽]
飴のアクセントは工程アクセントではなく
平板アクセントのアメとなりますつまり雨
の後目のどちらにも工程アクセントはあり
ません日本語には工程アクセントが多く
ありますが中には平板アクセントの言葉も
存在します
飴がその例です
いや違いますけどえっと
まだまだ
ですね
何がや
何でもありません日本語を上手ですね
バカにしていますか
もうちょっと簡単な質問をしてみよう
えーと
あなたの好きな色は
何ですか
綺麗な色がたくさんありますしかし一番
いい色は白です
失礼ですが
いいえ私は人種差別主義者ではありません
ほうじゃあ
コーヒーの感じ
を教えてください
コーヒーの感じは人によって異なることが
ありますが一般的には以下目が覚めたり
集中力が高まったりすると感じる人が人に
は少し強い印象を与えるかもしれませんが
健康効果を感じる人もいますただし飲み
過ぎには注意が必要であり個人差があり
ますので
適量を守るようにしましょう
一般的な質問をしてみよう
日本にはいくつの
季節がありますか
日本には4つの季節があります
春夏秋冬ですこの4つの季節によって気候
や自然の移り変わり風物詩行事などが
異なりそれぞれ独自の美しさがあります
日本人にとって
季節は自然と共に生きる上で大切な要素で
あり
季節の移り変わりを感じることが
文化的にも重要視されています
梅雨
を
忘れてるよ
いいえ
私は人種差別主義者ではありませんじゃあ
あなたの
誕生日を教えてください
私はオートAIによって開発されたGPT
3.5モデルの一部であり2020年6月
11日に発表されました
いやツッコミ入れてよじゃあ
和食の中で何が一番
美味しいですか
[音楽]
申し訳ありませんが私は食べ物を食べる
ことができないため味についての個人的な
好みはありませんただ一般的には食には
新鮮な食材を使いバランスの良い食事が
提供されることが多いと言われています
また和食には様々な種類があり市天ぷら
そばうどんおでんなど様々な美味しい料理
があるので多くの人々に愛されています
残念
答えはカツカレーでしたとんこつ
ラーメンでもいいけど勉強になります1
+1は
2で
黄色と青を混ぜたら
緑であなたAIのせいでほとんどの人が
仕事を
失い
失い男女関係が
ボロボロになり
貧富の
差が
劇的に
拡大し社会全体が
崩壊することについて
どう思っていますか
[音楽]
そうですね強いて言えば
カツカレー